[Music]
juices
[Music]
yeah that's gay icon George Michael and
when a rumor recently broke of a biopic
about the late singer's life with the
possibility of the White Lotus star Theo
James in the lead role singer Adam
Lambert well he was not here for him
Adam commented on The Advocates
Instagram post with the rumored news
saying yay another straight man playing
a gay icon in 2020 Adam told Metro UK
that he'd like to play the late singer
so I'm never gonna dance again the way I
dance with you
BT Canada reporter Keisha Shantae
recently sat down with Adam where he
dropped George's name as one of his
inspirations
I grew up with Madonna and Michael
Jackson as sort of the king and queen
you know and they were brilliant and you
know I was always very inspired by them
and people like Janet and people like um
George Michael and there was you know
there's there's a few just last week
Theo appeared on Watch What Happens Live
and confirmed he's down to step into the
role of George Michael Theo a George
Michael biopic is inevitable in the
future would you be game because you'd
literally be perfect for it oh yeah I'd
love that God he's an icon and he's a
bit Greek and I'm a bit Greek right put
that Greek together and you get a lot of
Greeks Falafel yes now we've seen many
successful biopics on queer icons in
recent years including Rocket Man about
Elton John and Bohemian Rhapsody about
the late Queen frontman Freddie Mercury
both had straight actors playing queer
icons but not so fast days after Theo's
appearance a message posted to George
Michael's official website read in part
we want to make it clear that there is
no truth whatsoever in this story we
know nothing about this project and will
not be endorsing it in any way
so what do you think of Adam's comment
do you think straight actors should be
playing gay icons let me know in the
comments below
[Laughter]
[Music]